- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy,
and many of you all know
about another project,
another not-for-profit that
I've been involved with
known as Schoolhouse.world,
which is all about giving
folks free tutoring,
and we do that by finding
amazing volunteer tutors.
Now, the tutors we've been finding,
they found a lot of reward
just being able to tutor other folks,
but we wanna make sure that
they also get other rewards,
because if you can tutor something,
not only does that mean
that you know the material,
but it also means that
you can communicate,
you have empathy,
you wanna spend your time
doing good for others.
So we were excited last year
when University of Chicago
said that they were gonna use
someone's tutor reputation
as a way to evaluate students applying
for University of Chicago.
And just a few weeks
ago, MIT also announced
that they were putting
Schoolhouse.world profiles
as an optional thing that
students could submit,
and the school will look at them.
To get a sense of the
amazing tutors we're finding,
this right over here
is the tutor profile and
the transcript for Karen Ji,
who's a high school student,
and you can see that she's
hosted a ton of sessions,
543 learners impacted,
33 countries reached,
864 positive ratings,
and you can see what people
are saying about her,
"My friend and I have been trying to go
to every single one of your
sessions for the past few weeks,
and we literally love you."
And we can go after page after page
of what everyone is saying about her,
and then what also
fellow tutors are saying.
So she's getting feedback
to become a better and better tutor,
and we also have the
certification mechanism,
which is qualifying her
to tutor in specific units
to show all of the things that
she has gotten mastery in.
This right over here is the
tutor profile for Kate Pearce.
So once again,
another incredibly amazing
high school student,
326 sessions hosted, over a
thousand positive ratings,
and what people are saying
about Kate right over here,
"She was very reassuring
and checks in with us
whenever we needed help
or got a question wrong.
Very helpful and patient
and broke things down."
These are things that you can't get
just through traditional transcripts,
the ability of someone like Kate
to communicate and
empathize with other folks.
So if you're a university or an employer,
who's really interested in
these types of students,
I encourage you to click on that form
in the link on this post,
and we can reach out to you,
and figure out how we
can build a relationship,
so that you can discover amazing talent
from the tutors at Schoolhouse.world.
So any young folks out there,
especially high school
students or college students,
who are interested in tutoring,
I encourage you to check
out Schoolhouse.world,
and I am going to work
with you and work for you
to ensure that the rest of the world,
college admissions officers,
and eventually internships
and employers and scholarships
recognize that one of the best ways
to prove what you know
and give back to others
is to tutor on Schoolhouse.world.